[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be tackling a question
theory that was sent to me via a
subscriber on Instagram if you don't
follow me on Instagram already then go
do it the question put quite succinctly
is this if Salazar said the Wren was
such an advocate for pure blood
Supremacy how is it that many centuries
later his owner Hogwarts house allows
half-bloods specifically we're going to
be tackling this question in relation to
the Sorting Hat as the hat is ultimately
responsible for student placement the
Sorting Hat magical artifact at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry has
the essential task of assigning new
students to one of the four houses
Gryffindor bufflepuff Ravenclaw orb
Southern each house was founded by one
of the four original founders of
Hogwarts godric Gryffindor Helga
Hufflepuff Rowena Ravenclaw and Salazar
sutherin the Hat was created when godric
Gryffindor pulled his completely regular
hat off of his head and made the
suggestion to the other Founders that
using their Collective magic they
enchant the hat and turn it into a
sentient being the purpose of this was
simple they wanted to leave something
behind that could carry on their house
legacies long after their deaths as long
as they were alive the founders could
easily select students for their houses
based on their own values and
characteristics but one day they
wouldn't be there which led to their
desire to leave behind something that
was capable of selecting students and
why was this so important you may ask
well each of the Hogwarts Founders
valued very different things imbuing
their own characteristics into their
respective houses these characteristics
would become the defining attributes of
each house these attributes can be
summed up in the Sorting Hat's own words
by Gryffindor the bravest were prized
far beyond the rest for Ravenclaw the
cleverest would always be the best for
Hufflepuff hard workers were most worthy
of admission and power hungry Southern
loved those of great ambition in essence
godric Gryffindor valued bravery Helga
Hufflepuff prized loyalty ruin a
ravenclaws or wisdom and Salazar the red
prized cunning and ambition however it
is certainly worth noting that these are
not the only traits attributed with each
house just some of the more noteworthy
ones to perform its task the Hat uses
legitimacy which is the art of magically
navigating through a person's mind as
soon as the hat is placed on your head
there's nothing it won't know about you
this is reflected in the Sorting Hat
Zone song there's nothing hidden in your
head the Sorting Hat can't see but one
major consideration that needs to be
made here is that Salazar slytherin's
vision for his house went far beyond
these basic traits we see he was a firm
believe her and supremacy of purebred
Wizards and sought to admit only those
with pure magical lineage into his house
and it was this very belief that created
tension among the other Founders and
eventually led to slytherin's departure
from the school given this history it
may seem contradictory that the Sorting
Hat designed to select students based on
the founders values would Place
Half-Blood Wizards like Severus Snape
Dolores Umbridge and Tom Riddle into
Southern house today I want to explore
the reasons behind the Sorting Hat
selection of half-bloods for Slytherin
despite the House's foundation on pure
blood Supremacy blood status is one of
the most controversial aspects of The
Wizarding World a concept in which
Wizarding families can be distinguished
by the level of magically endowed family
members generally speaking people are
slaughtered into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood
muggleborn or simply Muggle pure blood
refers to a witch or wizard who has
magical ancestry on both sides of their
family and has no known muggle
non-magical ancestors Half Blood refers
to a witch or wizard with mixed blood
and Heritage that is they have magical
abilities and come from a magical
bloodline but also have at least one
muggle parent or ancestor
muggleborn refers to a witch or wizard
with no magical ancestry who was born to
non-magical parents but possesses
magical abilities and lastly muggle
refers to a non-magical person with no
magical blood or magical abilities and
what's worth mentioning is that syrin's
vision for his house was not merely a
preference for pure blood students but
rather a strict requirement he believed
that only those who could prove their
magical Heritage should be admitted to
Hogwarts instilling this belief into the
very Foundation of his house so I ask
again what caused the infiltration of
half-bloods into the Slytherin house by
admitting them it appears to contradict
the values of the house itself the first
thing we need to look at is how
Slytherin house The Wizarding World has
evolved over time Hogwarts School was
founded in 990 A.D and with such a
considerable time span it goes without
saying that much changed in the
Wizarding World from then to now with
Slytherin house being no exception here
my my thoughts it would appear that over
the centuries Southern house sunderkon a
gradual transformation as the values and
beliefs of The Wizarding World evolved
while salazarin's original vision for
his house was centered around blood
Purity and the supremacy of purebred
Wizards I'm of the impression that the
house has since adapted to accommodate a
more diverse range of students and
values one factor contributing to this
evolution is the influence of the other
Founders on the Sorting Hat selection
criteria as the Sorting Hat was imbued
with the thoughts and values of all four
Founders it has the ability to adapt and
change its selection process to reflect
the evolving values of the school and
The Wizarding Community this means that
over time the Sorting Hat may have
placed less emphasis on blood Purity
when sorting students into Southern
house allowing for a more diverse range
of students to be admitted another
Factor contributing to the evolution of
Southern house is the changing values
within the Wizarding World as the
harmful consequences of blood Purity
beliefs and discrimination against
muggle bones and half Bloods became
increasingly apparent many Wizards and
witches began to reject these ideas in
favor of a more inclusive and
egalitarian approach this shift in
values likely influenced the students
sorted into Slytherin as well as The
house's overall culture and reputation
the presence of half-bloods and
muggleborns in Slytherin house also
played a role in its Evolution as these
students brought their own perspectives
values and experiences to the house they
contributed to a more diverse and
inclusive environment within Southern
this diversity allowed for a broader
range of qualities and traits to be
valued and celebrated within the house
moving it further away from Salazar
Sutherland's original vision of pure
blood Supremacy however despite these
changes it would be a lie to reject the
notion that the legacy of salonsas of
the Ritz vision for his house still
lingers Southern house continues and
will forever continue to be associated
with dark magic ambition and cunning and
its members are often judged based on
the actions of past slytherins who
upheld the blood Purity ideals however
the evolution of Southern house over
time demonstrates that it is possible
for the values and identity of a house
to change reflecting the growth and
progress of The Wizarding World as a
whole the growth of the Wizarding World
with regards to Prejudice as depicted in
the Harry Potter series can be seen as
an allegory for our own real world
throughout the series we witness through
harmful consequences of discrimination
Prejudice and the belief in the
supremacy of certain groups over others
and though our own world has made
significant developments over the
centuries I'd venture to say that we
like Slytherin house have a long way to
go but while this purported evolution of
Southern house is an easy idea to warm
up to I may simply be giving the house
too much credit it's entirely possible
that the placement of half-bloods and
muggled bones into Slytherin is the
product of something else altogether and
as it happens I've Got a Theory pad
which addresses just that scenario I
think it's possible that when enchanting
the Sorting hats godric Gryffindor
placed a loophole on the hand unbeknown
to the school's other Founders that
would undermine sutherin's advocacy for
pure blood witches and wizards godric
Gryffindor known for his bravery and
chivalry foresaw the potential problems
that salazarene's discriminatory views
could pose for the school and the other
Founders and in order to counteract this
created a loophole in assaulting hands
to allow non-pureblood students to be
sorted into Southern house this act
would ensure that the house would not
become a breeding ground for pureblood
Supremacy and would also help to promote
diversity and inclusivity within
Hogwarts I imagine that this loophole
could have been introduced in a few
different ways 1. subtly influencing the
Sorting hats decision-making process
Gryffindor could have included a hidden
enchantment that would encourage the hat
to consider non-pure blood students for
Slytherin house regardless of their
blood status 2. exploiting salazaren's
own enchantments Gryffindor might have
found a way to manipulate slytherin's
enchantments on the hats turning them
against his own intentions and allowing
non-pure blood students to be sorted
into his house
3. creating a Fail-Safe mechanism
Gryffindor could have created a fail
safe within the hats enchantment that
would activate if the other Founders
were no longer present allowing the hat
to sort non-pure Bloods into Slytherin
house in their absence this is just a
theory but it would certainly highlight
godric gryffindor's foresight and
commitment to ensuring that Hogwarts
remained her diverse and inclusive
institution it also helps that the Hat
they use for the Sorting Hat happened to
be one of godric's own another factor to
consider here is that it's never fully
explained why Salazar left the school we
know that him and the other Founders
disagreed and we know that he had a
major disagreement with God Gryffindor
prompting his departure but it's never
properly explained what the exact
Catalyst wants for this on this line of
thought it's entirely possible that
after unveiling gryffindor's loophole in
the Sorting Hat he simply no longer
wanted anything to do with his
co-founders
what do you think do you think that
Slytherin house has grown in a more
inclusive positive direction over time
or do you think that godric gryffindor's
responsible for the House's change let
me know down in the comment section
below until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live